m
ce massif aux relations
le super
ou les
tout ça
non
mais il
m
s'informer
alors
les nichons
voilà
aujourd'hui les gens du
métier
les cantons jours
comment allez vous
c'est
mieux
c'est lui
voilà
oui monsieur
ou plus
oui m
oui
lee
[Musique]
d'accord
j'ai envoyé pour ma tête
réponse
ou c'est 12 de parts
[Musique]
mais bon
et je prendrai comme
ces pollutions et
hop
[Applaudissements]
oui
et
[Musique]
de quoi donc
je n'ai encore rien lâcher
alors la liste des
éducation
sennels qualifie la fonction parce que
de qualité
les récents des conflits également
faites pour améliorer pour demain
avec un membre du personnel soignant de
temps vous c'est le retour des sacs
plastique en guise de protection qui
manque cruellement de matériel ils n'ont
pas de masques ffp2
également clairement la liste des 30
premières
j'espère longtemps que vous avez
à cambo gratuitement
il va
on a
c'est bon de sortie
on
[Musique]
ce qui est
silence
c'est la force
[Musique]
il y est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
c'est
[Musique]
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà
à
[Musique]
et
non non
[Musique]
nous
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
non
oui
m
[Musique]
on
il
[Musique]
oh
à
arrières
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
ma vie
nous
[Musique]
les zoulous
non
[Musique]
beaucoup
et
en minimes
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
g
mercier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la cité on a
et moi
bon là
aujourd'hui
situé
ce soit
non
et
le coup coc oui
non
il y est
il est rentré l'enfant
mais
oui
bashary
si
bordeaux
je veux
paris
non
j'ai cliqué dessus le site
on y est
il faut
découper tout sauf tranquille
ballon au fond
il est oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez
vous verrez
et
les autres
go
c'est pas
c
[Musique]
on fait
mais non
ou les
donner de
la tête
colère
oui
on est
ça
il veut
cette fois ci
il s'appelle
[Musique]
pour lui
et pourtant
photo ma santé
terre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
nationale
piron
je crois
ce
c'est
com
au milieu
sont ils ne risquent pas comme ça
oh oui
mais pas que
qui
bon
nous sommes en
[Musique]
oui
bonjour
un peu moins
[Musique]
m
le projet
[Musique]
je sais ce que vous
il
content
[Musique]
ou pas
moi
[Musique]
avant
ouais
[Musique]
m
ou pas
moi j'aimais mobilisation à l'actif de
dessus des mois voire des années dans le
sens du vent
ces
deux jours
en fait dans les termes proposés
sont pas nouvelles
exemple à côté de la plaque et on voit
bien
[Musique]
alors gardez vous ce fonds
notamment avec
les manu de façon ce sont les
valeureuses s'en sont ressenties ce
qu'ils font
heureusement parce qu'ils étaient
vraiment les aidera
moi
nous avons soigné
y a des
ja
la réponse est non
m
nos
abonnés
j'ai voté des nations
alors inventé à sa fin
[Musique]
mais
alors qui
[Musique]
obama
et
oh
oui
[Musique]
et
nous
[Musique]
oh
d
[Musique]
oui
d'un camion
et
oui
[Musique]
oh
mais
[Applaudissements]
nle
allez
enlève ses terres
[Musique]
et
non
[Applaudissements]
et
il
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
vous faites vos emplettes
op ambulancier au collet il a ses
repères et logistiques auxquels j boem
évoquera encore vinci leur collègue eric
pouce au caire éducateurs aux colères et
secrétaire open the summer auquel les
usagers
ok
a pris encore un truc après encore la
pédiatrie
interdit au coni
encore le surgit et jboss et autres
[Musique]
et après je suis très bien ici dans la
rue on a les crèches et pmi on vient
aussi du personnel soignant et saura le
crash et pmi du 75 qui sont avec nous me
salquain la petite enfance
de paris bran
la psychiatrie aussi qu'elle a beaucoup
de jeunes qui quatre y sont présents la
psychiatrie de loin ce qui est ici
clairement des lois ce qui s'est déplacé
jusqu'à paris parce que pour la
psychiatrie c'est la catastrophe avec
les manades aujourd'hui pendant deux
mois ils sont soit dans la rue c'est
plutôt voilà comment traite les plis de
jerricanes société c'est un scandale
c'est une catastrophe
pour ceux qui pensent qu'on est pas
assez nombreux c'est vrai que jamais
c'est même re mais dans toutes les
villes de france où il ya des auditeurs
des services station aujourd'hui la
démobilisation
des mobilisations à l'initiative de
l'organisation
l'un s'est jeté sur la cg c'est le
collectif veut de l'argent le collectif
soit elle est plutôt le collecte ou ce
tableau descendu d'un dessin à ph et la
muscle mais serge otis le proton la
psychiatrie
la coordination des comités de défense
des hôpitaux et maternités de proximité
aujourd'hui d'après les premiers
chiffres qu'elles ont à ce fait
plusieurs dizaines de milliers personnes
qui ont déjà mais je sais ce matin et
qui m'a manifesté cet après-midi une
vraie grotte est vraie révolte dans le
monde de la santé de l'action sociale en
france
le maquereau merlan sa fille si sage ici
depuis
on est dans la rue on s'en va vers un
ailleurs être entendue
dans les postes on va les amendes assure
serge aubin la récession
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chacun porte du tableau s'il vous plaît
à la quantité
[Musique]
m non
dans toutes les écoles
[Musique]
les autres
télé du jour
ici
les locaux
soit plus
je me sens la santé
qu'est ce qu'une bonne condition c'est
la raison
quand on
j'ai essayé aussi certains dossiers
mais j'étais
tués a chuté guérir delcourt messieurs
je souffre du dos
santos
et le jeu qu'est ce que c'est
[Musique]
j'ai pas
m
eros ont été démis
je sais déjà
ce choix
[Musique]
mais qui
c'est faux
oui ou non
des vins sont hors de prix et jean
fréchaut
s'il est sûr l'excellent mois
oui
bon faut lever les brevets sont nelson
jobim retail combler la cgt avec de très
nombreuses organisations onéreux
[Applaudissements]
prix et six enfants dont trois policiers
par croquer une odeur qui sont des
preuves
[Musique]
et
non
l'état
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
jean
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
les bars
[Musique]
les entités lieu d'être
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour moi
voilà l hôpital et au secteur
lac social médico-social
[Musique]
y en a marre de ce conflit
les années seront tendues entre points
d'eau poids que séville qui vient des
soucis de ces politiques là on
encore
fort de ce gouvernement qui n'entend pas
depuis trois ans nous sommes hors
indications sacrement c'est pas les
urgences les maternités qui fermait à
choucha qui sévit en route aussi parce
qu'ils ont envie moi il ne pouvait plus
accueillir les jeunes migrants mais je
sens en détresse les personnes âgées
dont les
politiques
j'ai pas bien dormi
tous ceux qui veulent casser l'hôpital
public
jeune yann autant du
résistant encore une fois
tout ce qu'ils veulent casser la
protection sociale nous allons répond
encore
le foie
alors vous êtes là
maquereau si tu savais tout rf en de
l'eau
et du médico social ou autrement aucune
aucune aucune hésitation non non non
intérêts somme bideau oui oui au progrès
social
oui
touchette qui veulent casser
l'assistance publique nous on a répond
encore une fois
j'ai pas bien entendu
et oui le seul accroc trois ans que nous
sommes dans la rue on supporte le corps
id on supporte la fermeture des
établissements
t é au support licenciements déguisés
aussi par toutes ces politiques qui le
conduit à moins d'offre de soins à
moindre coût social et à moins d'offres
médico social on n'en peut plus de cette
politique la
politique là
c'est pas bien entendu on n'arrête pas
macron cetus arrêts
à
marot ses seins
et
on sait mais aucune au cul aux
générations non non non intéressant
bidon oui oui oui en progrès social oui
oui oui au progrès social ah oui
christophe prudhomme nous le dit chaque
jour dans les manifestations c'est
possible il y a de plus en plus de
malades tous ne sont pas que coco vide
et vous le savez à chaque 2010 de fermer
les établissements et les services on
est en train de diminuer l'offre de
soins mais pire pire vous mettez tous
les professionnels dans leur parent qui
doivent choisir tel malade plus qu'un
homme parce qu'il n'ya pas de place de
cette politique la
porte cette politique là on n'en veut
pas et oui christophe dijoux scarlett se
passer là aujourd'hui cinquième vague
[Musique]
25e mag c'est surtout lhimer
aujourd'hui oui elle est malade comme il
mais il ya surtout beaucoup de mal donc
aux villes et on n'arrive pas à s'en
occuper parce qu'il n'ya pas assez de
lits et ses seuls plus gros scandale
dans un pays comme la france on a mis
l'hôpital à loos c'est ça la réalité
cent mille lits fermés en battant depuis
l'arrivée de monsieur macron pouvoir dix
sept mille lits fermés
la honte notre gouvernement
et alors sur paris quand vous avez
monsieur mayrand le ministre de la santé
qui osent répondre un député qui
l'interrogent sur l'opération bichat
beaujon avec 300 suppressions de lits et
monsieur verrons qui répond mais non il
n'y a pas de suppressions de lits parce
qu'on va construire en face de l'hôpital
à l'hôtel hospitalier mais de qui vous
moquez vous monsieur verrons c'est une
honte
c'est une honte
et vous dites médecin
honte à vous messieurs les ronds aux à
vous monsieur matheron la colère est là
on en a assez on en a 7 vous demain ils
sont vous médor
attention à ce que vous mettrez comme
bulletin de vote dans l'urne
on ne veut plus de cette politique là on
ne veut plus de cette politique
on ne veut plus de ces bonnes idées
claires
nacre au numéro gattex non y'en a cédé à
ces thématiques délétère qui consiste à
faire de la veille sociale kiko c'était
le prix de pau à la promulgation qui a
besoin de demain de tête de
0,4
les
usagers ne le pousse pas dans cette
écurie nous avons besoin de notre aide
sociale et piquant ce pilote
madrid tout seul
mais à quoi
sais tu savais
m
aucune aucune aucune hésitation
à terme bidon oui oui
on progrès social oui oui oui
et oui le progrès social ça se gagne et
on sent dans l'hémicycle décide de nos
vies de la gestion du pays et nous
promet la route à s'exprimer là répond
dire stop la place des politiques quelle
classe ne serez king qui cassent leur
métier et pire quelques astuces d'usagé
parce que les usagers eux ils
n'attendent que ça de vrai grand service
public
et si tu savais
notre ère c'est tout ça part en vrille à
mai
non
intéressant bidon oui oui oui au plan
social
à l'automne
soit
assurément collègues médecins au collège
éducateur spécialisé
l'école
j'ai pas bien entendu du rail où
le fleuriste
c'est son métier pour bien travailler
m
la fonction première
et maintenant
[Musique]
grâce à des entreprises
c'est ce que mort
il avait aussi
il y est
de sécurité
rires
ls
m
les sentiers
et ça on
il a
c'est ça
on se
qui
l'équipe avec un personnel
mais le prix est payée c'est mieux
j ai le même tu essaies de son champ
public
je viens de laïcité n'est pas une crise
comme trahison je connaissais tous je
voudrais vous faire part d'une situation
et que l'hypocrisie de l'administration
hospitalière
la semaine dernière il de nos collègues
infirmières me dis-je en est ce qu'on
peut décoller qu'à moi de l'hôpital de
soissons dans l'aisne sept collègues
soignants a pris une disponibilité
pendant cette disponibilité
elle a précisé que la dernière elle a
validé et elle son diplôme d'état
d'infirmière elle est sortie de l'école
d'infirmières en juin l'année dernière
2021 elle écrit à son directeur des
ressources humaines pour lui demander de
la réintégrer comme et dernière de son
directeur lui répond elle n'a pas suivi
la procédure en matière de faisabilité
donc je ne vous recrutent pas en tant
qu'infirmière diplômés d'état mais en
tant que toi nord
l'hôpital de soissons qui luttent en
recrutant dernière et qui manque
d'infirmières ses collègues que j'ai eu
au téléphone il a man c'est pas mon
secteur je suis du vin demain je lis
soit il ne veut pas toi essaie de
trouver un autre établissement
hospitalier
l'hôpital de château-thierry et
préfèrent recruter comme infirmière
diplômée d'état et le directeur de
l'hôpital de soissons qui s'est engagé
par écrit à ne pas traîner sa mobilité
et à la lutte et la bloque ce qui veut
dire que nous avons une première des
premiers d'état depuis juin 2021 et qui
fait office des soignantes et qu'on fait
trimer de jour comme de nuit à l'hôpital
de soissons calamars de ses
administrations maltraitance
les autorités en pleurs elle veut plus
voilà la réalité est l'adaptation
on utilise un pays shige ailleurs de
pitot
si le cas dati lui les officiels de ce
genre est représentée ici avec moi
[Musique]
ce témoignage
la souffrance il se sera durable
assure ne répond pas à ces questions a
même dit cette fille amélie et 50000 en
toit de l'hôpital public aujourd'hui on
se retient l'eau de la tête longtemps
dans il ne faudrait pas envie que nos
ehpad mais vous savez à quel point les
ehpad en souffler dans la période de
candide à quel point il manquait
justement de personnel et de kehl le
personnel qualifié et il avait de même
pour l'action sociale maintenant mais
nos services publics de l'action sociale
ils sont en train de faire une nouvelle
réglementation des conventions qui passe
avec le privé lucratif et c'est comme ça
que les établissements de l'action
sociale sont rachetés par des
entreprises lucratives
alors que veut-il faire avec ce lucratif
il veut que l'usagé paye et payer encore
regardé les 19 heures aux urgences
maintenant chacun d'entre nous qui
passeront aux urgences et qui ça peut
dire il est au samu on devra payer 19
euros mais c'est une honte
nous les pays de la protection sociale
et de la sécurité sociale le pays qui a
créé à travers le salaire le salaire
socialisé justement pour remplir les
cases de la seule sécurité sociale
justement pour répondre aux besoins
sociaux de la population y en a marre
c'est macron y en a marre de ce ver ont
arrêté de nouveau kembo ça suffit nous
dit aujourd'hui
ouvrez la boîte à pandore et la pointe à
30 ans il y en a du fric on le sait
tiana du jury alain monsieur macro ne se
verront vos politiques on n'en veut pas
mais vous voulez sûr et certain que nous
ne lâcherons pas vous qui les
présentaient un présidentielle aux
législatives en nous interprétant
interpellera sans cesse pour gagner sous
une revendication réouverture des lits
réjouit absolument les établissements de
proximité
employés embauchés dans tous les
établissements ont fêté le salaire en
france nous sommes les plus mal payés de
l'europe n'a gros
si tu savais
[Musique]
des réformes
macau
territoire où on sait mais aucune au qu'
aucune hésitation non non non
intéressant millions oui oui oui au
progrès social
vous êtes là
[Applaudissements]
un peu de musique
[Musique]
écoutez
et
mesdames messieurs les usagers la
population au café
sola
réclamer nos revendications n'auront pas
de calais améliorer nos conditions
[Musique]
m
alors les personnages les hôpitaux
de l'action sociale
comme sociale les services à domicile
m
la ville
écoutez son abri
allez
à
la clé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous les étés
[Musique]
tout
n'est pas aussi de recoller du secteur
privé secteur pour but lucratif qui est
un des patrons qui sont à la loi 10 mai
l'efs qui sont des tueurs
fous tout
tout arracher quand on bat saint prime
et ce sont des grèves très dures contre
elle régulièrement dans les
établissements pour simplement obtenir
un alignement des salaires sur les
fondations de records
on croit qu'on est mieux prise en août
mais ce n'est pas vrai ce sont les
relations paris centrale et des gens
[Musique]
thompson n'a pas démenti
qu'est ce que c'est
assis et y est financée par la sécurité
sociale concrets les actionner ça suffit
ça s'oublie
trois
métiers
et oui la santé une passion marchandises
et sans cesse de le dire sur tout seul
graves est de même christophe rousset
spycker les actionnaires en revanche
oubliez pas écouté aussi font qu'ils
sont plus des poches ce moment on de la
roche quel parent
mais qu'elle ne changera pas légumes à
moindre prix et gt line en public
et et avait tapé sur l'action sociale et
médico sociale publique pour que ça ait
aucune
pour que tout le monde ait la main non
pas sortir sa capitale mais sa carte
bleue là on voit le danger c'est adam j
g
man dont certains militants a expliqué
l'ex fait quelque chose nous on veut
absolument maintenir nos services
publics de santé d'action sociale et
médico sociale parce que si ces moyens
que n'importe qui soins de la population
sans discrimination
vraiment aujourd'hui on est dans la rue
demain on continuera à être dans la rue
mais jean s'est replié c'est aux
politiques gouvernementales et pour la
cher payé on n'a d'autre solution que de
manifester notre colère mais on a aussi
une autre solution prenons le temps tous
les jours tous les soirs avec nos
familles nos voisins pour expliquer ce
qui est en train de se passer jamais un
avis une état démantèlement des services
publics
il a passé une loi de la transformation
de la fonction publique
dedans il y a inscrit le caractère privé
lucratif ou encore ancienne avec le
lucratif et d'autres demandes du chis de
la rentabilité de la performance enfermé
dans deux enveloppes de deux dj de
moyens c'est une route aujourd'hui il ya
une députée qui est avec nous si vous me
le permettez mes collègues on va lui
donner un peu la parole parce que quand
ils se déplacent et qui viennent nous
voir
enfin on veut dire enfin on est un peu
écoutés merci de passer la parole à
notre collègue de la chanter députés
[Musique]
non là c'est mathilde de panneaux la
députée libre et donc je lui passais la
parole c'est bien qu'on soit ce qui
serait utile du lycée le masque voilà
avec le base comprend fond mais elle
nous a valu apporter son soutien c'est
toujours bien qu'on ait de nombreux élus
qu'ils soient là avec non ça serait bien
qu'il soit plus long - dans l'hémicycle
pour porter leurs revendications et
qu'ils sont enfin entendus ma tentative
[Musique]
bonjour à
vous
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous donc mathieu
panneaux présidente du groupe mathers de
la france je me souviens aussi agréable
qu'à kloten
et je ne sais pas où ils ont en tout cas
je voulais vous
au sein soumise
par ce que il est complète dans le pays
[Musique]
étant le cinquième pays le plus riche au
monde c'est à dire notre pays la france
il reste encore des gens à qui vous
dénie le droit d'être soigné parce que
depuis des années les soignants le
disent il faut des moyens humains et
financiers
pour que l'hôpital public et le système
de santé puissent tenir dit
messier travaillent et vivent et pour la
dignité de toute la population de tous
les passions des sorts le daisy
lowe jeunes
les tracks à travers les cheveux
les moyens financiers
faut que j'avance en même temps sinon ça
marche partout
si en plus de nous donner les horreurs
que tu as public ceux qui donnent
aujourd'hui si tu le sors vraiment
catastrophique
catastrophique avec un système de santé
qui pensent que les soignants sont
dévoués jours ils vont le faire tenir et
je dois dire
que dans un pays aussi riche que le
nôtre certains s'engagent jusqu'à n'en
plus finir tandis que celles et ceux qui
font un travail essentiel au pays celles
et ceux qui vous connaissent ville où
celui-ci tient sur le tir
aujourd'hui vélo pierre ce jour du
traité comme des sceaux et requièrent
ses idéaux et donc nous continuons à des
femmes non seulement système de santé
public dirty avec des moyens humains
c'est-à-dire des collègues au bout avec
des salaires qui sont dignes donc une
augmentation de l'immigration non le
ségur absolument rien réglé dans ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui dans notre pays eh
bien on continue aux
artistes question des politiques de
santé publique
born killers doit donner des mollahs
[Musique]
eh bien il est mort debout de petite
portée c'est qu'on est là je vois aussi
qu'il ya les acteurs notamment les ti
cats et par qui
merci à vous d'être arrêté ou interpellé
devant nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
merci du cadeau pour son soutien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
déjà dans les services manquent
non
merci
[Musique]
vrai
ce matin
le bassin je dois surtout dans la région
alors nicolas gay
oui
non
[Musique]
je
non
g
[Musique]
ouais
aubin
oh
oui
je pense pas
fabrication
ça
non
oui
on y est
[Musique]
non
alors qu'on voulait
les discussions ont aussi
[Musique]
vous avez 6 contre la fermeture et
empêcher un jour vous
la république
l'initiative désormais rice
qui aujourd'hui sont ensemble dans cette
journée action pour moi
ça suffit maintenant
vous écoutez m
comme nous sommes à diversifier
de presse
[Musique]
les eaux
j'aurais
[Musique]
et
celui conçu pour
[Musique]
quand tu écoutons
non
monsieur
[Musique]
on attend les
oui
qu'est ce que monsieur verrons
son rating
il
[Musique]
les effets
m
mais quand je vous remets je suis en
espèces
comme on dit tout
essayez
non
[Musique]
tout ce que c'est qu'il faut savoir
et
toute volée paris
parce qu'on n'a pas été bons
c'est
oui
ladite étude
pour eux
les
qui est le coupable
sa cuisine
notamment
2010deux
[Musique]
sollicité
pour que
il
et quels qu'ils soient régionaux qui
seront élus au poché cd chaud ce qui
nous intéresse c'est connu
es tu
population en deux ans être un peu
c'est comme ça
[Musique]
voilà
c
sorti chez nous sur
[Musique]
c'était
personne
non
cet été
ces tests
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si tu savais comme talleyrand
à l'automne 2010
tous les collègues sont épuisés et nous
mêmes
deux solutions de leur travail
[Musique]
est ce que c'est
le passé
écosystème plus tôt
[Musique]
toi on accède en saut
tout
ce que l'on me recueillir
non
ça se passe à
l'étranger
parce que na dia graciée
[Musique]
o'shea moshi jaune en métal et rap us
évidemment ça faciliterait pour toi non
essoyes
non
il
[Musique]
avec
shanghai chine
ça c'est bon
[Musique]
c'est pas simplement la retraite à 60
ans pour certains c'est vrai cliquez
on classe
qui sont ils
cp
qui va venir
tél
g
m
de plus compter sur lui
clean
je
chausson
et
on n'était pas dans l'action
pas toujours
mary kerr et son sérieux que ça pue
s'organise
[Musique]
8 et avec une ap
audrey m
[Musique]
il
hélas
[Musique]
il me
et
[Musique]
g
c'est tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
et
oui
[Musique]
doucet
il
c'est
et là c'est vrai
[Musique]
etc
tous
[Musique]
c'est tout
je
[Musique]
m
oui
[Musique]
comment
comme ça
et y
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
[Musique]
oui
bon
[Musique]
on
et
oui
[Musique]
les haies
élu
et
oui
jamais
vous
je trouve
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez
ce n'est pas hélas
oui
[Musique]
à
oh
mais toi
[Musique]
tél
oui
à
mais
qui est ce
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
foncez
g
m
tu fais
et il
[Musique]
à
[Rires]
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
mouais
les mois
sur la morale c'est bon
la banque reconnaît qu'ils craquent en
ce moment il n'ya pas décollé on a eu
une explosion
hepatology quintrec aujourd'hui c'est
catastrophique
le buzz heureusement nos collègues dans
les structures de psychiatrie sont
complètement débordés ils n'en peuvent
plus on l'a fermé des lits
on a plus de capacités de prise en
charge des enfants qui vont pas bien que
vous avez également être papa bien connu
prochain rendez vous c'est dans six mois
comment pour y porter sa voix la réalité
aujourd'hui
santé est aujourd'hui trop
ce secteur si la prime qu'ils allaient
céder mal il intéresse personne ces
maladies
et
certains disaient
vous pouvez juger
[Musique]
oui
et
mangani
quand on voit comment traiter qui
aujourd'hui sans les erreurs on savait
que y'a un peu packard sont des gens qui
se trouvent en prison et dont il espère
qu'il va bénéficier prise en charge qui
catherine kate on ne propose pas
d'augmenter
si tu as aimé lambert
politiquement
une pécresse
je vais partir
allez plus
oui ou non
je restais
l'humanité
[Applaudissements]
m
mais toujours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
qui veut que
8e
elie brun
qui nous
le
[Musique]
ap le second
du tout
ouais
atelier
qui veut dire qu'ils sont
et
lundi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
avec
oui
[Musique]
il est
boucher
je suis je
si les mots
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est librement
le jeu
on continue d'y
aller
lundi
[Musique]
je
comme attendu
[Musique]
alors
oh
ou pas
non
et
oh
chercher à la vie là
oyonnax
[Musique]
il touchera
aux gens
aucun
non
la maladie
[Musique]
on est deux
ministères des outre-mer
le cadre de
épidémique notre gouvernement est traité
non compatriotes d'outre-mer
de manière digne
je pèse mes mots
[Musique]
il faudrait monsieur maquereau ou la
première peu à respecter les gens et à
respecter la douleur parce que quand on
refuse de reconnaître les méfaits de la
chlordécone
faut comprendre que les gens puissent
être en colère et c'est en les insultant
qu'on gagne leur confiance monsieur
macron c'est en les respectant et en
discutant
chien à nos collègues nous trop mais qui
sont en grande difficulté
désormais tout élaboré à leur insu
les
construit voilà quelles conditions
aujourd'hui on serait beaucoup trop même
au goût peut traiter et de compatir et
outre-mer comme voulez-vous fait ces
derniers mois c'est l'énergie
un cascadeur
famille
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
t
[Musique]
à
il
[Musique]
elle
là
m
mon avis
c'est par les enfants
[Musique]
les personnes âgées
qui
m
n'écoutez pas les passions chez makro on
croyait trop là
sont inefficaces
qu'ils évitent aux libertés qui aura
bien possible autant à kourou jours dans
ce pays
aujourd'hui ce qui est important c'est
que l'hôpital puisse accueillir des
malades et pour cela vous n'avez rien
fait depuis trois ans rien rien pour
former les personnels pour les embaucher
le ségur n'est qu'une aumône ça l'a fait
que rattraper la perte de pouvoir
d'achat l'iréo cocaj des salaires depuis
2010 et surtout monsieur battre surtout
votre bilan à quelques mois des
élections présidentielles c'est la
fermeture de 17 min 17
aujourd'hui dans les echos vous avez
poursuivi et accéléré la politique de
vos prédécesseurs
donc on est amoureux vous ne pouvez pas
nous expliquer c'est pas de votre faute
vous pouvez pas nous expliquer qu'il
faut du temps pour former les personnels
soignants ce n'est pas vrai ce n'est pas
vrai y compris pour les réanimateurs tu
nous manques vous n'avez pas augmenté en
nombre suffisant le nombre de places
pour les internes en réanimation il faut
dix ans où il confond le médecin mais
pour former le terne en réanimation il
faut quatre ans et au bout de trois ans
ils sont déjà autonomes bugs vous n'avez
pas pris les décisions qui étaient les
bonnes ce que bon vous réclame depuis
2019 c'est à dire donner les moyens à
l'hôpital public et à ses personnels de
pouvoir s'occuper et dignement et si tu
as mot de tous les patients qui soit un
tas de la commune ou d'autres
pathologies
vous n'avez pas donné les moyens aux
ehpad vous n'avez pas donné les moyens
ou secteur du médico social
vous l'avez pas d'eux des moyens au
secteur social qui souffrent aussi
beaucoup parce que quand on est en crise
comme celle qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
eh bien vous savez le collègue a centre
social elles sont très importantes dans
le système c'est un ensemble le système
de santé et le système d'action sociale
ce sont son métier et pour cela et bien
il faut former les personnels il faut
embaucher pour que ça puisse fonctionner
et vous ce que vous proposez c'est la
poursuite des plans de rigueur alors si
on est conne un certain nombre de
candidats
il faut encore supprimer les postes de
fonctionnaires parce que les
fonctionnaires ce sont des fainéants
bah oui bien sûr
l'expliqué un collègue aide soignante
kiska sono a soulevé les malades parce
qu'un parent matériel que c'est une
fille ans tu
vas nous expliquer l'unesco
thiollière qui courent pas mal entendu
parler parce que
voilà ce qui peut en même temps
politique et sessegnon
a expliqué
qui prend en charge
l'accident de la route sans sessegnon
mais cette
pression
et il
est aujourd'hui
c'est mon pognon et rien pour les gens
qui servent pour la société comme nous
les soignons
comme tous les personnels les hôpitaux
parce que l'aja par des soignants aura
beaucoup les soignants mais nos
collègues ouvriers administratifs
et vient et c'est aussi important pour
faire fonctionner le système voilà s'il
ya un mal à condamner satisfaire les
commandes et qu'on aux ruptures de stock
on sait comment s'y au palco les
ouvriers pour réparer chauffage on fait
comment voilà c'est ça la vraie vie pour
un peu redescendre sur terre monsieur
meron monsieur macro 11 qui m'ont uranio
pour l'hôpital public pour former du
personnel ont augmenté les salaires nous
il faut
d'ailleurs pas pu tenir
pour une aide publique
mannion lundi à
12h18
il faut des sous aimez-vous mais hérésie
ce maquereau on va aller chercher
parce que nous on veut tout de suite on
tentation nos salaires on veut seulement
des hanches on veut des michel en
hauteur et tous nos populations pour
tous les états mais sans à oui c'est ça
fonctionne depuis trois ans que dans la
gestion de ce politique leur qui
consiste à tout réduire à tous fermés on
n'en peut plus on est en souffrance
partout personnel exigé est fauché
personnel épuisé il faut chez makro
[Musique]
terro
[Applaudissements]
aucune organisation
n'a
rien accordé
au progrès social
[Applaudissements]
musical et six nuits je me plongeais la
présidente de la coordination des
comités de défense des hôpitaux de
proximité qui mobilise énormément de
monde dans les petites villes pour
défendre les hôpitaux de proximité dont
on a énormément besoin à toi ni sans toi
[Musique]
tu penses que l'élite pour mémé pu
déborder sur gruissan
2 mauvaise affaire pour les mercenaires
chez les messieurs chercher parce que
on côtoie a voulu acculer qui fonctionne
qui est le seul biais accessibles à
toutes les couches de la population qui
fait tous nos combats que nécessaire
quand je sais qu'ils se divisent alors
oui il ya besoin que de quelques stocks
de bureaux pour l'hôpital public pour
qu'elle fonctionne comme il faut et pour
qu'il puisse répondre aux besoins de la
population
comme toi et j'ai tiré des coups de feu
en ce moment
particulièrement importantes dans de
petites villes parce que c'était là où
les gens ont besoin de lever d'un public
d'autant plus que pour les rendez vous
vaud
harvey les médias il faut former les
personnels et le gouvernement n'est
toujours pas compris le change cela fait
plus de vingt ans que l'on dit qu' il
faudrait supprimer les numéros scottish
le gouvernement sur ses propos et qu'en
réalité est depuis 20 ans mais un défi
de mort pour régler la question mais si
on attend encore d'être enfin vers une
catastrophe est-ce que valable pour les
médecins c'est valable pour l'ensemble
des personnels pour former en grand
nombre et pour ceux là aussi ont du
pognon
mais la santé d'abord l'hymne et je
pense qu'on est tous d'accord là dessus
et je peux vous assurer qu'il n'y a
actuellement en france aujourd'hui des
manifestations dans de très nombreuses
lignes en bas rien parce que c'est le
besoin de la population
merci messieurs les voiliers messieurs
les retraités aujourd'hui c'est
l'essentiel médecin anesthésiste de
l'hôpital public à charleville mézières
continuer à mener la lutte avec no mercy
shell
[Applaudissements]
on va passer la parole à une aide
soignante du groupe korian qui est
également conseillère municipale s'est
consacré à une belle écharpe donc à la
fois au boulot auprès de nos anciens et
aussi elle se bat au quotidien une
nouvelle de la nation à toi
bonjour à tous très heureux d'être tous
à vos côtés du pari que je suis est juan
york je m'appelle si une charge lui et
seulement à l'ehpad de korian les
merlettes la sacem c'est vrai que nous
avons malheureusement une situation très
critique concernant la leucose id on a
beaucoup de salariés malheureusement qui
sont clichés actuellement on avait
réussi à se sortir de ce que vivent mes
balles le sirop unis nous avons des
résidents mais grâce à la bonne prise en
charge de nos collègues nous nous
arrivons s'en sortir donc
malheureusement il ya six résidents mais
c'est pas aussi catastrophique l'année
dernière et puis en tout cas nous avons
lutté pour obtenir le matériel avec
toute l'équipe de la cgt korian
et puis je remercie aussi la santé fsp
je remercie aussi tous le public des
hospitaliers les instituteurs aussi
qu'ils sont là ils vont pas les oublier
voilà on va s'y tenir jeudi prochain
venez nombreux à cette mobilisation
parce que tout le monde est en
souffrance d'accord je veux aussi leur
camarade malik avait le redis qui a
amené un très grand combat à nos côtés
et puis la thalie marchand je vous
remercie à tous pour ce soutien merci
merci on va faire les secteurs honda
et qui a truqué en grande difficulté
représentant d'une association à qui
regroupe à la fois des soignants des
patients des familles de patients des
citoyens
voilà pour la défense de la psychiatrie
publique et pour qu'on s'occupe de nos
faux diamants et humainement oui parce
qu'il faut savoir qu'en france dans les
années 50 on a décidé de sortir les fous
d asile où il était relégué voulait
soigner dans la cité et leur redonner
leur statut de citoyens
c'était une chose extraordinaire on
appelle ça le secteur psychiatrique dans
tout le territoire il avait 1 c'est un
secteur qu'ils étaient dans l'obligation
de prendre en charge tous les patients
toute la souffrance psychique des plus
bénins ou plus grave et l'essentiel du
chemin donc était plus l'hôpital mais le
secteur le centre médico-psychologique
les soins ambulatoires
c'était extraordinaire le problème comme
l'a reconnu véran mois de septembre
depuis 40 ans on a appauvri la
psychiatrie le résultat c'est que on a
commencé par un arrêté faire de la
prévention et puis on a commencé à trier
les malades prenons environ les moins
malade pour peu à peu faire en sorte
qu'aujourd'hui si vous n'êtes pas très
malade vous n'êtes plus suivis par le 5
le secteur psychiatrique
et pourtant malgré tout c'est rit
aujourd'hui la psychiatrie crève de
manque de places de manque de moyens
pour accueillir toutes les demandes
donc les patients sont envoyés vers le
libéral et la plupart du temps c'est le
médecin généraliste
qu'est ce qui fait un généraliste
ben il donne des médicaments
et ça fait que des patients pour avoir
des médicaments toute leur vie
simplement parce qu'ils n'ont pas des
espaces de psychothérapie où ils peuvent
travailler leurs souffrances
aujourd'hui quand vers ans a reconnu cet
appauvrissement on s'est dit ben on va
peut-être enfin avoir les moyens de
soigner correctement et de remplir nos
missions
d'autant que les conditions sociales du
coc vide je pense que je n'ai entendu
parler ont révélé une mettra ordinaire
épidémie de décompensation psychiatrique
ce que ce soit les adultes notamment par
rapport à la crainte du chômage ou le
chômage que ce soit les adolescents en à
canon et son ordinaire de jeunes
suicidant où les tout petits qui parce
qu'ils ne sont pas en lien social avec
les autres enfants ont des retards de
langage ont des retards de la relation
cox il faut un véritable plan d'urgence
où la psychiatrie et qu'est ce que fait
vers ans il a décidé que pour les
adolescents en leur père à 10 séances
deux psychologues libéral à condition
qu'il n'y ait pas de psychothérapie
c'est d'un côté on va simplement faire
du comportementalisme de la méthode coué
pour leur dire t'inquiète pas mon gamin
tout va bien c'est scandaleux alors que
dans le même temps aujourd'hui on
pourrait et c'est un des rares secteurs
de la santé qui aurait cette chance
pouvoir embaucher immédiatement des
milliers de psychologues qui n'ont pas
de poste dans l'hôpital parce qu'on n'a
pas de poste à leur offrir
et qui sont au chômage ou qui ont
renoncé à leur travail donc on pourrait
en tout de suite embauché des mythes et
psychologues ce qui permettrait à la
fois d'absorber les listes d'attentes et
de recommencer à soigner ils comprennent
la prévention mais ça ne suffit pas au
gouvernement
avec la loi de financement 2022 il vient
d'apposer le fad puisque la psychiatrie
des pédales wah tour elle est censée
intégrer le parcours de soins alors
qu'elle était conçue comme un parcours
de soin spécifique aujourd'hui on est
censé comme la lame la cardiologie
intégré de parcours de soins c'est à
dire que si vous avez un point de
cardiaque le cardiologue ne va s'occuper
que de moments de crise d'un être en
place la traite pas vous allez voir le
médecin généraliste pour le suivi mais
ils ont décidé que la psychiatrie c'est
pareil
vous êtes en crise vous êtes suivi par
le secteur de psychiatrie mais des coups
s'est stabilisée vous rend tourner dans
le parcours de soins et si le
généraliste qui va vous suivre lorsqu'on
est que lorsqu'on souffre de psychose de
dépression très grave même si on est
stabilisée on va pas bien et aujourd'hui
si ces gens sont stabilisés c'est
justement parce qu'il bénéficie d'un
suivi permanent dans les centres
d'accueil thérapeutique à temps partiel
ou ils préfèrent des activités ou des
consultations au centre médico
psychologique qui leur permet justement
de tenir le coup si on supprime ça on
sait qu'ils vont des compensées et le
généraliste ne pourra pas les suivants
et bien pour accélérer parce que bien
sûr la réalité n'est pas aussi simple
que le voudrait le gouvernement et que
dans la réalité ou
lui encore beaucoup de passion trop de
patients stabilisés selon totalement
c'est encore super psychiatrie donc on
met en place un dispositif
d'exclusion des patients qui s'appelle
réhabilitation psychosociale c'est un
bon mot réhabilitation psychosociale
invalidé qu'on va redonner une dimension
citoyenne à cette personne edano il
s'agit d'une programmation comme s'il
s'agissait de machines ont fait une
évaluation de départ on l'a on les
soumet alors se brise ou mais des
programmes et ses salles comme ça on les
programmes et à la fin de la
programmation ont fait une nouvelle
évaluation pour savoir si leur suivi
sera simplement le généraliste où il
sonnera pas m en plus du médico social
c'est scandaleux
c'est
inhumain et je pense que ça montre aussi
la manière dont notre gouvernement
considère l'humain dans sa globalité
voilà
merci j'ai passé la parole maintenant
les restes ivala que la secrétaire
général de la fédération cgt de la santé
l'action sociale qui va le dr tu peux
les informations sur la réponse qui a
été fait en particulier à la demande
d'audience auprès du cabinet du premier
ministre cameron
déjà vous dire que nous étions plus de
3000 hi-fi à paris
nous sommes démunis du salarié il fallu
créer une identité secrète et du social
mobilisés aujourd'hui on attend devant
les ars que les préfectures et vit à
paris il faut le souligner et ils ont
remercié tous les salariés qui se sont
mis en mouvement malgré les difficultés
et malgré les restrictions que nous
subissons dans les établissements nous
avons fait une demande d'audience au
premier ministre et au président de la
république de manière unitaire avec les
neuf organisations qui sont incapables
de cette journée en avant une aucune
réponse est non maintenant partir
d'aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
et nous en envoyons nous allons envoyer
tous les jours nous de cette année cette
demande pour qu'enfin on nous répondre
le mépris en tout cas pour les
professionnels de ne pas répondre à une
demande simplement d'audience c'est
inacceptable
et vous pouvez voir que non ce début
d'année ce gouvernement n'a pas changé
et onguents méprisés
personnel fasse ici maintenant les
belles promesses nous voulons que en
belyzel de enfin de revendications
soient entendues et nous ferons tout
pour
augmentation du salaire qu'elle ait vécu
dix églises soient enfin retourner et
que leur donne leur traitement
complément à 8 eur 283 euros mais ce que
nous voulons pour tous les
professionnels c'est plus de salaire et
une augmentation qui tienne compte enfin
de nos compétences de nos qualifications
comme tous les autres pays qui nous
entourent d'europe où les fautes
professionnelles sont mieux rénumérés
qui suit au froid seat in indigne d'un
pays comme le nôtre de continuer à nous
mal payés et alou m'a traitée de la
sorte les conditions de travail sont
indignes nous ne pouvons plus accéder à
nos emplois nos congés c'est
insupportable
il est temps que nos gouvernements forme
et ont créé par minier des
professionnels la cgt demande 400000
emplois il est temps que ce gouvernement
rendre dans des négociations pour nous
faire voir enfin qu'il a décidé de
former et de recruter du personnel
et en ce qui concerne le financement de
notre système de santé trop d'exemples
ce certes il est temps aussi que ça
serait la priorité de ce gouvernement
mais comme ce gouvernement ne va pas pu
être à présent encore longtemps
nous attendons des candidats la
présidentielle peut faire une priorité
la priorité dans ce pays de la question
en tout cas de la santé de notre système
de santé est une priorité la question
des salaires pour nos professionnels et
pour tous les citoyens français sur tous
les salariés qui considère que c'est le
pouvoir d'achat aujourd'hui qui fait
défaut aux nombreux citoyens et nombreux
salariés de ce pays et en premier le
fais bien les questions de santé action
sociale et nos conditions de travail qui
doivent perdre en tout cas être un des
thèmes des thématiques ou des
thématiques que des contenus doit dans
ce ventre en avant je vos rondeurs fine
leur participation nous avons encore
encore de cette année à trouver ensemble
des mobilisations et débute la semaine
prochaine il y aura ni d'énergie dans la
rue le 27 unef l'office
interprofessionnel avec des
organisations dans la cgt pour les
trouveurs d'achat et on compte sur vous
aussi pour être présent plus nous serons
nombreux plus nous pourrons peser et
l'éducation nationale nos collègues ont
les mêmes problèmes que les autres il
faut les soutenir ils seront le
mouvement jeudi en mouvement de grève
un certain nombre de gens qui ont encore
un sirop mais qu'ils participent aussi
dans le secteur à les activités
essentielles
[Applaudissements]
sur les bras
les fans dans les pales on l'a trop
d'heures que deux fois on adore aussi
qu'on s'occupe de nous les anciens voilà
pour pouvoir continuer à sourire
et à profiter il sociale il vieillit en
communauté parce que c'est pas toujours
facile on n'est pas d'or dix mois qui
peu comment ça se passe chez toi avons
dû question ce que vous vivez
alors on n'est pas de l'avis des pays
dans le matin il se lève il mange le
midi mange le soir ils mangent tout le
reste du temps c'est la vie sociale
c'est du vivre ensemble et nous notre
métier en tant qu'animateur cette veuve
favoriser ce vivre ensemble
et pendant le cosy dont on a été tous
mobilisés comme vous on a fait des
insultes comme joue et nous les
animateurs on s'est retrouvé à faire des
métiers qui étaient pas les nôtres les
métiers pour lesquels on n'était pas
formé mais on a aidé nos collègues et
entre non il fallait qu'on continue à
favoriser la vie sociale parce que comme
vous savez c'est une période qui était
très compliqué pour les personnes âgées
quand on est privé de la visite de leur
famille et on sait à quel point c'est
essentiel boom et on était là pour les
aider dans ce sens là on leur proposant
des skype en leur faisant des visites
tous les jours autant que faire se peut
parce qu'aujourd'hui le quota
d'animateurs on y va de ses seins pour
60 à 65 résidents alors imaginez pendant
qu'on
dit maintenant pouvait aller voir une
cinquantaine une soixantaine de
résidents site est impossible mais on a
fait de notre mieux tu vas faire des
heures sup quitte à partir tout chez
nous rentrer tard chez nous parce que
c'était essentiel comme les soins
voulant fait ou qu'on dit au quotidien
avec eux et nous c'est ce que revendique
une meilleure valorisation de notre
métier une meilleure reconnaissance de
notre métier et lorsqu'il ya des
augmentations de salaires l'oscal ségur
on a été oubliés comme de nombreux
métiers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
aujourd'hui
c'est un besoin vital
les autres d'oublier ce sens avec
l'éducatrice spécialisée dans la
protection
de l'enfance est essentielle
c'est rihanna nations les enfants et
donc on a besoin cezelly quatre heures
c'est que très spécialisés à toi merci
bonjour alors moi je teins d'âme
exprimés pour tous ces jeunes ces jeunes
qui les points à devoir attendre des
mois pour pouvoir être prise en charge
parce que nous n'avons pas de structure
on a montré assez de personnel pas assez
de places déjà naquit à 18 ans on leur
dit je voudrais fond de la rue vous
pouvez y aller on a pas de place pour
moi on va éventuellement leurs deux des
contrats jade majeurs jusqu'à 21 ans
mais c'est pas suffisant qui à cette
heure ci à 18 ans ou à 21 ans peut
prétendre êtes autonome et pouvoir gérer
sa vie c'est juste impossible un système
en mettant
en avant les jeunes on les met en échec
dès le début qu'on leur dit prenez des
fois des formations courtes non vous
n'avez pas le droit aux études parce
qu'on ne pourra pas vous financer ce
n'est pas normal il faut que nous ayons
plus de structures que nous donnons plus
de chaînes dans sa chance à ces jeunes
et nous en tant qu'éducateur nous sommes
épuisés nous n'aurons pas ces structures
comme je le répète nous avons des
éducateurs réellement épuisé la moitié
de mon équipe est en arrêt maladie nous
n'avons plus de cadres et ce système
n'est juste plus possible falloir que ça
bouge et ça passe notamment justamond
par la revalorisation
les attend pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si vous voyez que la santé l'action
sociale gisin à l'hôpital c'est sans
métier mais la santé action sociale se
mettre plus de 100 métiers ces deux
millions cinq cent mille salariés et on
travaille tous dans l'humain et c'est ce
qui est oubliée dans ces sociétés et
c'est ça qu'on réclame aujourd'hui c'est
d'avoir les moyens de pouvoir
humainement prendre en charge nos
résidents nos passions des jeunes dont
on a la charge en termes d'éducation et
on va de la parole à une autre camarade
qui
voit là il a des matrices en centre de
loisirs aussi que cette histoire
[Applaudissements]
quand la parole pour tous les animateurs
à la fois on a dit aussi en on nie pas
mais aussi tous ceux qui agissent pour
les enfants
dans les cadences 24 notamment les
accueils de loisirs et c'est un pétard
c'est vraiment sinistrés encore plus
avec la situation sanitaire on a un
protocole qui change régulièrement quasi
quotidiennement et fait le maximum sur
le terrain alors que on va dire que dans
le tente au mail on a déjà beaucoup de
temps devant les jeux très très sécurisé
là on se donne à fond mais on a des gens
on a beaucoup d'arrêts maladie on a des
gens qui sont révisés et ce au détriment
des enfants et notamment aussi des
enfants en situation de handicap parce
que notre fondement de plus en plus de
choses à faire et d'accueillir des
enfants parfois très différents et qui
ont des besoins spécifiques voilà qu'à
signer couple
passé la parole à une assistante sociale
dans des centres d'accueil pour les plus
précaires tu vas nous expliquer aussi
ces problématiques
bonjour à tous si je vous encourage
vivement en fait de ne pas surtout lâché
donc moi je suis une assistante sociale
dans un centre d'hébergement d'accueil
de réinsertion des personnes dans la rue
orientée par le samu une et xiao
chaque fois qu'on a que ces personnes
déboutées même des malades avec des
problématiques sicafi on n'arrive même
pas fait à faire face qu'avec juste
notre du moment et un autre secteur à ne
remplit pas pour notre métier à chaque
fois qu'on me demande aussi des moyens
d'accueil sur dix appartements parce
qu'un appartement a éclaté donc en livre
déficitaire on n'a pas les moyens donc
moi ce que je demande à ce gouvernement
de vraiment prendre en compte ces
personnes parce que on est devant fait
des maltraitances des personnes
apparemment dans cette année
le respect à la dignité de ces êtres
humains suite à un accident dès les
aléas de la vie un jour l'idée prend un
jour ils avaient un travail est toujours
le lendemain ils se retrouvent à la rue
suite à une expulsion et on n'y peut
rien donc il faut vraiment le pas lâcher
prise
oui parce que je vous rappelle que
certains qu'ils ont oublié la santé
c'est le bien-être physique
psychologique et social voilà donc ça
c'est important quand même non j'ai
passé maintenant la parole à aline oui
allez la presse
oui donc on a parlé aussi de l'action
des enseignants dans joly donc vous
savez les deux services publics que les
libéraux veulent massacrés c'est
l'éducation et la santé donc je pense
que l'on doit être solidaires pour
défendre ses deux grands services
publics qui sont essentiels pour le
vivre ensemble
oui bonjour à tous du coup je suis prof
à sarcelles en fait sous 95 sais pas si
vous avez vu mon essayé de pousser à
mort dans l'enseignement pour est en
grève et vous donner une partie de profs
qui sont grévistes dardé d'avis h et
cetera parce qu'on avait vraiment pensé
que la nécessité cette aide est de vous
rendre aussi visible non pas d'effacer
par nos revendications mais on les
partage complètement on a les mêmes
revendications sanitaires qui sont
catastrophiques on se fait éclater comme
vous depuis la rentrée c'est le chaos
dans les écoles c'est le chaos dans les
collèges c'est le chaos dans les lycées
et tous les personnels sont malades on
emmerde les gosses on emmerde les
familles n'en peuvent plus il ya zéro
centime qu'on était quand il déposé sur
la table pour nous aider en fait à
combattre on fait semblant soi disant
qu'à des tracas de l'aide ya de l'action
oui soir une à des interventions blanc
caire de castaic etc nous sommes
effectivement il ya une grève qui a été
posée demi a énormément d'enseignants
qui son soutien avec vous avec la santé
klaus au sein du service par les
services sociaux on a un lien permanent
sans fête avec vous et non par contre
moi je viens on va pas attendre de
demander au gouvernement en fait le
gouvernement nous méprisent mombasa axe
de défense depuis ça fait maintenant
deux ans on a les mêmes revendications
tous on n'a rien on n'a pas attendre qu
à ce que le gouvernement ils nous
apportent en fait il va falloir
augmenter un rapport de force pour
pouvoir les dépenses et en fait vous
pouvoir les forcer à nous donner des
moyens consentant ce concept organisent
entre nous il ya un petit air de
bataille des retraites la qui fait du
bien franchement que vous ça fait
plaisir d'être avec vous les soignants
avec les travailleurs sociaux et des
rats grosse face à vous en tout cas on
mobilise des âges et on invite aussi à
refaire les ag interpro qu'on avait
faite au moment des retraites si vous
c'est bien avant que le coc vide nous
assaillent est ce parce que c'est là en
fait on n'avait pas perdu si vous
souvenez bien on n'arrête pas de perdant
face des négocations soir étaient les
négociations soient les dehors dans la
rue et nous aussi on veut dre visible
avez-vous parce que
[Applaudissements]
il ya plein de soignants tu peux pas
être ici sont en grève qui peut pas être
ici tu passe des semaines dans les labos
dans les pharmas et que c'était à tout
le monde et blindés y'a rien qui était
faisable organisation catastrophique ils
peuvent pas été c'est donc ça nous les
autres travailleurs aussi d'être là pour
les représenter en fait pour qu'ils
existent sinon peuvent pas tous est là
donc je suis sûr qu'à bien plus de
personnes ya beaucoup d'enseignants en
grève dès aujourd'hui et donc on
reconduit et on espère aussi aller
parrot je viens avec nous beaucoup de
secteurs ça va être assez historique
n'hésitez pas rejoint à mettre de la
force à refaire les âges et de secteurs
les ag de ville les agendas eu ça
c'était vraiment le plus progressiste en
fait qu'on l'ait vu et a énormément de
familles si en fait ya énormément de pas
tu sont précaires les mois paient les
poux ont massacré le plus de tâches ma
chance tite et vous verrez c'est là où
on est on ne peut plus passer leurs
notes plus de tâches on a les salaires
les plus bas et que c'était il ya
énormément de familles c'est aussi donc
on a nécessité de serrer les coudes et
faire nos agents collectif courage à
vous on est nombreux et avez vous
continué le mouvement et puis à jeudi à
paris à pékin avec les tout le personnel
de l'est du très bas on est tous en
marge de la même façon courage amis
merci
dans l'éducation avec les parents dans
la santé avec les citoyens aline qui se
bat pour le maintien de l'hôpital de
l'hôtel dieu à paris avec un comité de
défense qui regroupe pas mal de monde
dans le centre de paris à thoiry merci
et bah écoute moi je suis d'accord avec
la caméra dans ces encarts un enseignant
il faut vraiment qu'on mette le paquet
jouer long
mais nous
la défense de nous dit elle quinze ans
de paris et de nourrir de remotiver
compliquent et deviennent aussi du
communiqué les paris combinés on s'est
compris l'acte iv ans hier à l'hôpital
on a fait un brouillard d'énergie
position de free quence rigole et gérer
certains analystes aux enfants on est
tous risques ou du grand favori 10 y ont
été ouvertes à pays qui est quand même
le président de
bruno bini ont de paris déjà connu un
bond d'un tiers des écoles du magnifique
0 1 donc c'est lui et move majorité de
la majorité
majoritaire de la majorité qui veut sud
de départ ce soit sur la procession à
cet hôpital nord quel dieu c'est pas mal
on sera encore là pour réguler juste
pour nous et au canon sur l'adhésion
modification n'est pas non plus au sujet
de paris ils veulent rien faire nous
avons des alliés ne re restaurant
gastronomique
vergès né à revin mouillage de carreaux
on n'en a pas la privatisation ni la
santé lise l'école ni dans ical contre
la spéculation et on fait avec les
enseignants aussi jeudi
donc je ne sais pas par là d'avoir un
pierre car éducateurs spécialisés
collègues qui sait la petite enfance
parce que dans la petite enfance les
collègues pour travailler pour garder
les enfants pendant la crise qui cela
qu'ils n'ont aucune reconnaissance a pas
eu d'actes distingue après le ségur
gardien eut à toi
bonjour j'ai du qatar spécialisée doha
gâtés des jours éducatifs et
pédagogiques
du coup on a vraiment seraient reconnues
en frais des gamins qui sont un peu dans
la merde et ce qui vaut pour terme
d'étagères rythme
ils ont le gaillard de fous rires je
passe la parole à vous aurez tous les
cas la bulle y est
depuis j'ai élu chercheur en salles dans
leur coeur pour les beatles et
ah bon
et c'est la guerre
à copenhague les stages que les gens
avec ma trouver des stages c'est quand
même catastrophe et dans la petite
enfance assez difficile aujourd'hui
vas-y la pyramide bonjour alors je
représente les camarades de la petite
enfance qui ont merdé
alors on a tous beaucoup de peine à
faire la guerre pour toi parce qu'aucun
travail à charge mentale en un peu comme
je l ai vraiment confessionnelles donc
si un gars comme draveil bas salaires
ont fait ou les mairies bon faut mettre
les parents dans l'est le corps et
l'esprit
mon propre et tous des familles il faut
seulement que miniser donc me payer on
est retraité innover effectivement on
est considérés tu es mal parce que c'est
comme si on passait nos journées à jouer
les enfants et vidéo un métier facile
qui le petit détail technique alors que
pas du tout s'occuper d'un cancer
demande un élément
michel mental bonjour je vous remercie
de nous lègue manifester et de poser à
nous quand vous travaillez vous gardez
vos enfants donc si nous voulons les
commerces
je garde
hyper pense donc la gold il ya des
hommes
je n'ai pas le reconnaître
nous on habitue les enfants être en
collectivité chargée pour les vingt-sept
père à l'école on en fait de l'achat
canon et d'où l'échec est long pour une
guerre économique
[Musique]
merci donc merci à tous pour cette
journée comme l'a dit pire elle s'avère
paris parfois même les camarades qui
viennent de prendre ce soit levé sur est
jamais très nombreux parce que faut
savoir que c'est difficile à paris pour
venir la grande banlieue c'est plus
difficile qu'elle veut dire deux îles en
tgv ou de lyon mais aujourd'hui
réellement là on commence à voir les
remontées ya eu des mobilisations
partout y compris dans des petites
villes dans une petite ville de 1500
habitants ailleurs un ehpad des gens se
mobiliser pour une heure ou sont sortis
dans son communiqué ça va donc c'est que
ça notre force c'est la multiplication
des actions pour que
votre gouvernement qu'on est toujours
mobilisée dans la diversité vers une
bande de métier étaient représentés
aujourd'hui parce qu'on travaille tous
pour la même chose bonjour lady ya pas
que ce soit lui réduire la réanimation
s'occuper d'un enfant c'est prendre soin
lui dollars pour publier ça donc on doit
être tous solidaires
discuter autour de vous mobiliser fait
signer les pétitions que y ait le
maximum de gens qui participent aux
initiatives en syrie nous y at-il avec
dix ou quinze personnes un endroit c'est
ça qui est le terreau pour qu'on puisse
créer le rapport de forces pour qu'on
soit entendu et comme le disait mireille
que la santé l'action sociale le social
devienne une des thématiques de la
présidentielle et qu'on se préoccupe
réellement que ce secteur qui a été
laissé à l'abandon par les libéraux qui
le gouvernent et qui pensent qu'au
pognon et ses atouts ses vingt-deux
jeunes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hlm jusqu'alors la campagne profonde
la mairie
[Musique]
notre place on
on attendait dans un palace on n'avait
pas la cptaq
m
mais laury 1104 et ils ont dû nous
diviser
qu'ils y sont privés dans le fictif
leur système de pensée et indien
il était 6 mai
[Musique]
il nous parle d'égalité et comme et dont
les acquis démocratiques venant m'avait
si c'était ça aussi
on va jouer
ces commissaires con carne
bien que les prises et que pèse le droit
des landes
il est revenu
ce vendredi
la république sont constitués banques
tu es tu
oh
[Musique]
tellement content de ma balade d'une
part lipides fraternité quand des sdf
sur la dalle et qu'on mène la chasse aux
sans papier qu'on jette des miettes on
peut le terrain juste histoire de les
calmer qui sont elles parlent pas tous
millionnaires précieux très serré c'est
fou comme ils sont protégés une origine
en puissance y'a pas à dire ça fait des
économies du président chers camarades
chers lecteurs chers citoyens
consommateurs le réveil a sonné
remettra sur les commentaires quant à
lui ya un espoir dans le cas de la riaa
du compas dans le combat c'est qu'on est
debout tant connu on lâchera pas la rage
de l'ain compte dans l'oreille
maintenant que c'est pourquoi aux par
l'oxydé âge bien plus carré
avant la série
aulas
oh
deux mois
[Musique]
la suite
oui
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
il
à
[Musique]
marteau
car à part
non
[Musique]
les
trois jours
[Musique]
avant
m
[Musique]
là
quoi
[Musique]
on voit beaucoup
m
[Musique]
les femmes aussi
a priori non
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok
g
[Musique]
et
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m